* Yawning * Almost all vertebrates are metabolized. Penguins do it as a mating ritual, snakes
Do this to reset the jaw after a meal, and guinea pigs do so to show anger. so why
Exactly human beings are mocking? Is yawning really contagious?
If you have not already seen a video yawning-O-METER, click here, or use the link at
Description, to see how long it will hold before yawning. If you like us,
You may even have just read the title of this video.
The truth is, the first time you've ever been proven likely when you're an embryo. Children start yawning through
Chapter II of pregnancy, although the cause is still unknown, it may be due
For healthy brain growth. In adults, yawning was thought to normally attract more oxygen
To the lungs and makes you feel less tired, but new research has shown that it may not be
As well.
Scientists now believe that yawning has been developed as a functional means of cooling the brain.
Like a computer, your mind works better at a certain temperature and tries to avoid
"High temperature". It became clear that yawning increases heart rate and blood flow and use
Your facial muscles are all necessary to cool the brain. Moreover, that
Deeply inhaled cold air changes the blood temperature in our heads.
But why does your mind heat up in the first place? Well, both fatigue and sleep deprivation
Are known as reasons for increasing brain temperature in general, which explains why yawning occurs more in
These cases. Research has found even participants who put hot packs on their head increases yawning 41%
While watching the others mumble, versus 9% with a cool pack on their heads.
If your head is already cold, you will be less depressed. But what about mass infections
To yawn?
Humans, monkeys and dogs even find yawning contagious, and are most likely skillfully linked
Sympathy. Vaginal yawning begins in children aged 4-5, and this behavior
Of empathy develops, along with the ability to identify emotions. In fact, children
People with disorders related to empathy, such as autism, wander less when watching videos for people
Compared with other children. Research also suggests that you are more likely to copy
Yawn from someone close to you socially or genetically. Likely to even dogs
She yawns from her husband in exchange for the yawn of a stranger.
Finally, symmetric neurons play a role in it. In the brain, symmetric neurons are released when
We begin to implement specific actions, we see someone else actually doing or even just hearing someone
Talking about the verb. They are important brain cells and are used for learning, self-awareness
And communicate with others. When we see someone yawning, symmetric neurons in our brain
Become active in a similar way, and as a result we reproduce yawning.
Although yawning may occur in people who literally have "hot heads", yawning infection
Allow us to be cool with the people around us.
Sign up for more weekly science videos!